hey what's going on it's bill burns it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast and
ah
i'm just checking in on you
just checking in on you
all right oh i'm in a mood
oh
freckles
the old brown spots are simmering today
on his [ __ ] nose
jesus christ a buddy of mine
sends me a text message and he's like
motogp was great this week you might
want it but you got to check out the f1
the uh the f1 was incredible
all right so i'm thinking oh my god this
we got some racing
we got some racing going on we got some
passing we got all of this [ __ ] going on
right
and i'm watching the race
and it's great ferraris are out front i
don't know why they're maroon now
but i'm enjoying that max verstappen's
out there you know that perez guy's
driving for red bull i'm a little behind
in the sport so i'm like oh wow some
[ __ ] jumbled around
you know daniel ricardo's all the way in
the back of the race because he's
driving some [ __ ] [ __ ] box
ever since he left red bull which is my
problem with that sport
is it's really the team that you're with
is is is
is bigger than the driver's skill
because when ricardo was with red bull
he was getting podiums all the time he
was winning races he was drinking out of
his [ __ ] boot
you know now he's in the back of the
race
it's the same driver
different team you know so anyway
speaking of which i'm watching the race
and i'm like look at mercedes struggling
lewis hamilton fifth sixth place the
whole [ __ ] race right
and i'm like all right this is good
finally some new [ __ ] blood you know
i know mercedes will get the car dialed
in this is good right
so we get to the end of the race john
leclaire ferrari [ __ ] first place the
other ferrari driver is in second place
max verstappen is in third and perez is
in fourth
and lewis hamilton is in fifth
all right and then driving there's like
five [ __ ] laps to go all of a sudden
this guy's car catches on fire
lewis hamilton is completely out of the
race
and out of podium right [ __ ] guys car
catches on fire they got the new rules
they do the [ __ ] restart whatever the
hell it is
now he's in the leader group and i'm
like here he comes here here comes the
rich kid this [ __ ] [ __ ] the
richest car out there
oh for [ __ ] sakes i'm not answering
that
um yes i still have a house phone
um
do i need to ask someone to answer that
ah
hang on hang on
hello
oh jesus christ have you really been
trying
[ __ ]
trying to reach me for my car's extended
warranty
we've been trying to reach here hey cars
they said you're a robot [ __ ] off okay
let me guess you have a diamond mind
that i can invest in and then you'll
cover my muffler
um
anyway uh
yeah he's like in fifth [ __ ] place
they get to like the second to last lap
all of a sudden max verstappen's car
just dies
just [ __ ] dies
nobody passed anybody it dies
so now lewis hamilton is in fourth place
he's almost on the podium and i'm
thinking how he's gonna pass perez here
we go and he can't cause his car [ __ ]
sucks right so i'm like oh great the
rich kid finally having a tough race i
get to watch him pout one of my favorite
things in the world
watching lewis hamilton sitting in his
car with his helmet on
acting like the world just ended because
he didn't get on a podium i i'd say no
it's the little things in life
ever since i saw that i saw botos be a
teammate for him and then like six races
later it's like five years ago the exact
same scenario
was presented where lewis could have
hooked up botox and he's just like yeah
no i'm not doing it and i was just like
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] you
that's it i'm done with you right so
now there's one lap to go
lewis hamilton cannot catch up
with perez and by the way ferrari is
going to be one and two for the first
time in like 46 years at this race
announcers could give a [ __ ]
they're doing what they always do
screaming and lewis hamilton is now in
fourth place right i swear to god the
guy's voice is that high
they get to the final [ __ ] lap the
other red bull car just dies
it she goes around the turn the engine
just [ __ ] dies and he wipes out and
lewis hamilton and the [ __ ]
announcers
oh my god this is incredible what a race
who would have thought it oh lewis
hamilton is now in third place ebay
lewis hamilton makes the podium
screaming the whole [ __ ] time
guys coming in third place they said
lewis hamilton more than they they said
ferraris one and two
and then they told me it was an
incredible race not because ferrari went
one and two not because lewis hamilton
passed two red bull cars on the final
two [ __ ] laughs because both cars
[ __ ] died
and they're so excited that the goddamn
golden boy
gets on the [ __ ] podium it was the f
and my buddy had the [ __ ] balls to
tell me that that was a good
race then i get to see you know what
he's like he's like the [ __ ] in every
coming of age 80s movie except in the
end he's still banging the cheerleader
ah you ever think you could get this
worked up about people driving cars
you know what it is it's this it's just
they were acting like he passed somebody
he didn't pass anybody
it's it's the same reason that i don't
like the nba i don't like the [ __ ]
at least when daniel stern was running
it and he used to just rub his balls
he'd paint his nut sack purple and
[ __ ] gold and just root for the
lakers to make the finals every [ __ ]
year like openly
like well date not daniel stern that's
the actor david stern what's your dream
final oh the lakers versus the lakers
then they have a mobbed up ref who
helped the lakers get there but stern
wasn't involved no not at all not at all
that guy ran a nice tight ship
the whole time he was there
that that league wasn't finessed
whatsoever yeah yeah the knicks won the
lottery in 85 and got [ __ ] patrick
ewing abso [ __ ] lutely absolutely i'm
buying all of that [ __ ] i'm buying all
of that [ __ ] you know
the [ __ ] kevin garnett trade oh yeah
that made total sets and all of a sudden
i don't know you know with this the nba
needs you know it's just the ratings are
down let's just get the lakers and
celtics going again let's just give them
that finals two years ago okay sounds
good
dial it up
um
no one can tell me differently i
literally heard an nba player one year
when they lost in the playoffs he goes
yeah we just didn't fit their script he
literally said it
and people still sit there
and act like that the most easily
manipulated [ __ ] game out there
oh look at that great player he could do
some damage today there's two quick
fouls and out of the game you go um all
right sorry anyway lewis hamilton is in
third place
can you believe it it's unbelievable
what what a race it was fantastic it was
brilliant
spectacular
he came in third place
i don't know what's more hilarious to me
watching those announcers
screaming about lewis hamilton getting
third place in a race or watching
vladimir putin score a goal in a pickup
hockey game i don't know what is more
ridiculous to me
um or to use the great dennis miller's
uh reference uh
elvis presley
look at that i was so worked up i hit
stop on the record um the great dennis
miller's reference uh el watching elvis
presley do karate
dennis miller had this amazing joke a
long time ago and one of my favorite
stand-up specials of all time the black
or white special black uh no the
off-white the off-white album no that
was the album
i think was the black and white special
i think about the [ __ ] oh my god i'm
[ __ ] old it was like 30 years ago so
he had this um
now i have to look it up that's gonna
drive me nuts
um he had this joke saying so and so
deserved something about as much as
elvis presley deserved his black belt
[Laughter]
um
oh black and white
right that was a stand-up special that
was it yes um
yeah mr miller goes to washington in
that two huge specials
for all young billy burr
when i used to watch stand-up comedy so
um anyway
it was still fun though um you know
i and by the way for all you lewis
hamilton fanboys i know that guy is
[ __ ] amazing
okay and i know his story is amazing it
is amazing okay without a [ __ ] doubt
okay but i just you know
jesus christ the guy came in third place
all right he didn't just cure covet
[Laughter]
oh my god it's unbelievable lewis
hamilton just went through a
drive-through and ordered a big mac
andy got the fries
oh that's hurting my voice lois hamilton
i drive my wife nuts when i watch the
the [ __ ]
the races because all i do is scream
acting like that [ __ ] guy
um
anyway so another week done another week
done on the movie uh people i have a
week and a half left um
you know as mentioned before i i could
not be having a better time but i am
wiped out
i had you know i've been getting as many
of my friends in on this movie as i can
two of my buddies came in this past week
did a [ __ ] great job
they were getting laughs after the take
the takes uh
worked with a
beyond a legend
legendary actor um
this past week can't name any of the
[ __ ] names because that's how this
game is played but um
it's been good man i've been staying on
my diet although you know
um we do have food trucks come down
and uh we had these
fried chicken sandwiches and i was like
[ __ ] this i'm doing that all right
i've been eating the protein
the size of the palm of my hand with
green beans they're all
[ __ ] weak
i'm eating nuts and berries in between
[ __ ] this
i'm getting the fried chicken sandwich
the nashville hot fried chicken sandwich
with the coleslaw on it at the curly
fries
and a [ __ ] root beer
and it was abs i was so psyched that it
was delicious
because i was talking
to um
my laugh this morning
telling her how good the hot chicken
sandwich was because
you know those things are really it's
not even hit or miss it's usually a 90
misses and then a hit
because um
you know
i really feel like fried chicken is like
pizza
where like anybody can make it taste
good
but to make it taste great
like there's just so many okay pizza
place like if i was to pick one food
that there is
you know
i don't know just an infinite amount of
okay pizza places that stay in business
just cause it's pizza like i don't you
know that's one of the [ __ ] things
with like the
[Music]
um like the restaurant business
evidently is one of the you know
scariest businesses to go into you can
totally lose your shirt and all of that
type of [ __ ]
and um
you know
yeah you can lose all your [ __ ] money
but you can i think the safest bet
the blue chip stock is to go in and get
and make a [ __ ] you know start a
pizza parlor
because at the very least as long as you
got a location even if your pizza sucks
your pizza absolutely sucks but you're
just on a corner where there's going to
be a bunch of drunks
pouring out of a bar every friday and
saturday night you're going to be able
to meet your [ __ ] overhead
just filling their bellies with your
mediocre [ __ ] it's cheese tomato
sauce and dough
right
and all the drunks allowed themselves
you know it's it's it's soaking up the
alcohol i love that it soaks up the
alcohol in your stomach and it's like
yeah but then you don't puke up the
pizza the pizza stays in
your stomach and then goes into your
system it's one of the dumbest things
ever
i need a slice of pizza
i can absorb some of this alcohol it's
no different than what are they they put
alcohol
in a fruit punch bowl
um same thing so i'd say that and then
fried chicken
there's another one so um
you know i'd say i'm not like blowing up
a spot out here because there's a line
like it's disneyland is uh howland ray's
is the best [ __ ] chicken fried
chicken sandwich i've got in la and it's
not even close it's [ __ ] amazing and
then yesterday this food truck came up
which i didn't get the name of because i
was too busy
wearing a you know
down the [ __ ] set and the sandwich
just came but it was [ __ ] amazing i'm
gonna get the name of their food truck
so i can give them a shout out because
they [ __ ] killed it and everybody was
you know
everybody was excited so i was happy
with that but i will tell you that
because howl and ray's was so good but
their line is so [ __ ] long that i've
tried to find another place and i've
given up
i've given up i'm just like you know
what
you know there's really not another
place
out there although i will tell you
there's a spot in glendale
um
but it's not like hot chicken or
anything like that called dinah's
chicken it's an old school place
that place is [ __ ] great
every once in a while when i'm on that
side of town
you know
and i'm in the mood i swing by there
and i get a [ __ ] tupish and i'm very
happy
mashed potatoes because i'm a white guy
from the suburbs you know
which i didn't realize mashed potatoes
was like a northern
like european [ __ ] like like to me
like mashed potatoes are a [ __ ]
staple
of so many meals
you know you have a pork chop you have
mashed potatoes
thanksgiving dinner you have mashed
potatoes
you know
you make a steak em you have mashed
potatoes i'm just saying like you know
something that's the best kind of
[ __ ] potatoes around mashed potatoes
with [ __ ] gravy
you know
this is before everybody got all foofy
with the food channel put rosemary and
garlic and i'm just was [ __ ] mashed
potatoes milk butter salt go [ __ ]
yourself gravy on top
was the greatest thing ever with a roast
beef [ __ ] meal and the carrots thrown
in there too
under seasoned you know like the german
irish food that i ate growing up it
wasn't until i got with my lovely nia
that she's like you have mashed potatoes
i was like yeah she's and she was like
sweet potatoes
and i was like what is a sweet potato i
literally never had one
[Laughter]
and she thought it was [ __ ] hilarious
that i had mashed potatoes
for uh
for thanksgiving
and i was looking at her like
you don't have that's a big [ __ ]
thing huh i bet with like married
couples
you know
you come together with somebody
right you know
and if you marry outside of what you are
and i'm not even talking like racially
if you're just married like you know if
you're irish and you marry into italian
like italians have like that that uh
that fisherman's feast whatever the [ __ ]
that is the seven [ __ ] courses or
whatever
tom papa was teaching me about that
it's all this [ __ ] seafood and
lasagna and [ __ ] and i'm just like this
is thanksgiving like where's
thanksgiving is turkey [ __ ] mashed
well maybe that's their christmas i
think that's christmas
it's turkey
this is my okay this is what this is my
[ __ ] go-to's
all right
at a thanksgiving dinner i don't give a
[ __ ] if i'm at the white house i'm
walking out if there's not
that'd be [ __ ] hilarious
can you imagine getting invited to the
white house for thanksgiving
you know and they didn't have mashed
potatoes and stuffing
and you're just like yeah i'm out i'm
out where you going i'm going to boston
market
it's [ __ ] thanksgiving i don't give a
[ __ ] if they have chicken down there you
don't have the right sides
that's the real deal with thanksgiving i
don't know why i'm talking about this in
march
because my head's [ __ ] spinning from
doing all this [ __ ] but i'll tell
you right now you don't have the right
sides
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] your family
and your thanksgiving oh yeah oh i went
there look at first i was i'm yelling at
the golden boy lewis hamilton in this
silver arrow of a mercedes he's in ninth
place
all right i have to stop doing that
it's just hurting my [ __ ] voice
um
jesus christ can you go in the house or
out of the [ __ ] house damn kids man
in and out in and out
um
all right hang on a second let me do uh
let me do the reads here for the week
why don't i do that
so i'm [ __ ] screaming about men
driving around in cars
i literally got off my couch like you
got to be [ __ ] kidding me
when the second one [ __ ] the bed
all right bet mgm oh look good everybody
oh my god it's tournament time it's
tournament time and how about a shout
out
to coach k
getting by uh
michigan state
and coach izzo
who's at his number all these years and
they're still
alive i mean you got to watch every duke
game
i swear to god i swear to god even when
i'm [ __ ] home i can't [ __ ] relax
every five
[ __ ]
minutes is [ __ ] crazy
every day every day there's five
thousand [ __ ] my wife's a planner
she's always planning something there's
always 50 000 [ __ ] people coming over
here to do something
to do something
[Music]
dumbest [ __ ] things you can ever do
is get a [ __ ] alarm for your house
anytime anybody [ __ ] goes out listen
to that [ __ ] thing
why wouldn't you just leave the door
open if you're gonna go in and out like
that
all right bet mgm everybody it's
tournament time riff about college hoop
excitement well i'll tell you right now
oh boy oh boy when those kids paint
their faces and and that guy goes oh
he's a prime time player baby do i
really need a riff about college hoop
excitement it's one of the best things
ever
that's going to get ruined pretty soon
pretty soon pretty soon these kids will
start getting paid
you know and then it's just going to be
just like the pros i mean i'm not saying
they shouldn't get paid but right now
you know what i mean it's kind of like
the ufc eventually they're going to
break up that monopoly so as a fight fan
you really have to enjoy
that the best have to fight the best
before inevitably that that'll get
broken up and it'll be like when boxing
became uh i'm the i ibf heavyweight
champion i'm the wba heavyweight
champion i'm the wbc heavyweight
champion which one of these champions is
the real champion
all right if you haven't signed up for
bed mgm yet
use bonus code burr and you'll get 200
dollars
free after placing your first 10 bet if
any team hits a three-pointer during
march match-ups here's how it works
download the bet mgm app and sign up
using bonus code bur place your first 10
money line bet at any march madness uh
march match up game you'll receive 200
in free bets immediately after placing
your bet if any team hits a
three-pointer during march matchups
regardless of the outcome just make sure
you use bonus code bur when you sign up
oh look who it is everybody it's helix
everybody helix
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else
with helix you're getting a mattress
that you know will be perfect for the
way you sleep everybody's unique and
helix knows that so they have several
different mattress models to choose from
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattresses great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot
[Laughter]
mattress why did you just [ __ ] have
less covers mattresses great for spinal
alignment to prevent morning aches and
pains i could use that and even a helix
plus mattress for all you big boys
you know you big ladies all the big bone
people huh
um helix has been recommended by
multiple leading chiropractors and
doctors of sleep medicine as a go-to
solution for improving sleep you know
somebody told me the other day if you
smell a little lavender if you rub
something you know on your hand and you
smell it it'll help you drift off to
sleep too imagine if you had that one of
these great mattresses jesus christ can
you imagine the sleep you'd get just go
to
helixleep.com take their two-minute
sleep quiz and they'll match you to a
custom mattress that will give you the
best sleep of your life helix even has
financial options and flexible payments
plans
uh so a great night's sleep is never far
away helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at
helixsleep.com that's helix sleep
h-e-l-i-x
sleep.com
for up to 200 off all mattress orders
and
two free pillows
okay masterclass everybody
with masterclass you can learn from the
world's best minds anytime anywhere and
at your own pace you can learn how to
write from david mamet
or aaron sorkin how insane is that do
you i hope you young kids realize
how unattainable information like that
was
i mean
it's insane
i remember coming up just watching those
guys movies going how the [ __ ] do they
do that now they're on this thing going
hey here's how i do it improve your
cooking skills with courses from
wolfgang pup puck and gordon ramsay
learn music from tom morello and herbie
hancock what more do you need here you
realize if this [ __ ] was around the
internet was around like 50 years ago
learn how to play guitar from jimi
hendrix with over 100 classes from a
range of world-class instructors that uh
that thing you've always wanted to do is
closer than you think immersive learning
experience cinema quality classes that
give you unparalleled access to a
renowned master lessons range from
specifically showing you how to execute
a technique to a master's insights about
their craft that can be translated
across many fields and disciplines learn
by doing with sessions by completing
real-world projects following a hands-on
30-day curriculum with step-by-step
guidance from our world-class
instructors masterclass is accessible on
your phone web or smart tv offering
classes on a wide variety of topics all
taught by world-class masters at the top
of their fields each class is broken out
into individual
video lessons usually around 10 minutes
long i should do that tom morello one
maybe finally break through
and get out of my stupid cowboy chords
level of [ __ ] playing guitar um each
class is broken out into individual
videos lessons usually around 10 minutes
long members can explore at their own
pace and each class is supported by
downloadable materials lessons recipes
or more hundreds of video lessons from
100 plus
of today's most brilliant minds are
available anytime anywhere on ios
android desktop apple tv amazon fire tv
and roku i highly recommend you check it
out get unlimited access to every master
class and as a monday morning podcast
listen you get 15 off an annual
membership go to
masterclass.com now that's
masterclass.com for 15 off masterclass
guys i got to tell you something there
is so many horrible things to watch on
the internet that actually really damage
you mentally and probably make you a
worse person over time
there's very few things or whatever this
is the part of the internet you should
go to master class
i mean they got something there that
will
it'll bring
positivity and joy to your life
to get better at your hobby or maybe
it's something you want to do for a
living you should definitely check it
out it's an investment in yourself all
right and the people around you because
you'll probably be in a better mood all
right
now that right there is what's known as
a ringing endorsement okay we have
reached the end
of the podcast so at this point now that
i've calmed down
um i'm not mad about the bang bing bang
bong and the [ __ ] front door right
now i just realized it's the alarm guy
coming over here fixing the [ __ ]
alarm
all right
i am a little upset that there's people
out there that cold call people to try
to steal old people's money
do you know there's a new scam that they
[ __ ]
they say they kidnapped your kid and
they have like the recording of a kid's
voice
to try to get your money
like let me read this here just so you
guys are wise this is kidnapping scam
yeah but then what if it's real and
you're like yeah that doesn't sound like
my kid jesus crisis virtual kidnappers
scour the internet for targets
by searching for social media posts by
international travelers scammers then
contact the target's loved ones claiming
to have taken the targets hostage family
members are connected into paying a
ransom quickly to ensure the target's
release
so there it is if your kid is traveling
internationally watch out for scammers
um
god it is such a [ __ ] dark world
oh my god
i mean i would just be so relieved when
my kid called i don't think i'd even be
mad that they took my [ __ ] money but
those people that do that should be hung
by their [ __ ] balls
and [ __ ] lips if it's women whoever
whoever's doing it all right that's it
everybody that is the podcast
um the nhl playoffs are coming up nba
playoffs are coming up i'm almost done
with this movie i want a movie i want to
thank you guys for your patience
listening to these
half-hour episodes uh as opposed to
hour-long episodes at least on monday
anyways um
that's it i got anything better it's
going to be getting back up and running
soon um that is it and uh enjoy your
weekend you [ __ ] cats oh wait um
there's a little bit of music here and
then whatever bonus
um
a bonus episode of the thursday
afternoon just before friday monday
morning podcast that's it i will see you
as
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
march 24th
2014. what's going on how are you
i'm uh back in the united states oh
say can you see
[Music]
that [ __ ] fat
chick with the pockets
buying a hot dog it's in a bun
right as i get
off the
tarmac
and she puts on some frost sorry um
i didn't see that some reason i was
picturing a fat woman with the pockets
that are at least a foot apart
you know what i mean
i don't know why i was thinking that i
don't know i'm but i'm back
i'm in my house it's nice to be sleeping
in my own bed after uh you know three
weeks being away
it's nice to see that my house is still
here and that the people i love are
still uh in fact not in detention camps
um it's weird being away that long and
then coming back i'm still uh still a
little little out of it man
you know i'm not a young guy anymore
takes me a couple of days
to settle back into my routine you know
gumming my way through some [ __ ]
grape nuts that i let soak in the
[ __ ] milk
you know
toss a little banana on top of it you
know it's funny every time i go to get a
banana i deliberately don't take the one
with the sticker
on it i take that one last because i
worked with the comic who had a bit
about it and every [ __ ] night i had
to listen to him do this bit about how
and which one do we take the one with
the sticker and then what would you do
you'd stick it on your forehead and he
kept [ __ ] opening with the joker
closing with the i just heard it six
times
i'm talking like 15 [ __ ] years ago to
this day i will not take a banana first
that has a stay occasionally i do
you know
and somewhere i hear him going see i
told you
and i'll be like what do you mean you
[ __ ] told me i i that's like once in
a blue moon
and then there's the ghost of his voices
going yeah but you're doing it on
purpose if you didn't hear my bit you
would have done it every time so my
joke's right it's like you know what go
[ __ ] yourself go [ __ ] yourself what are
you doing talking in my head okay this
should just be me and all my friends not
you you're not invited all right so [ __ ]
you and your your your theories about
the fruit that i consume
all right all right everybody it's
[ __ ] march 24th okay and if you live
in a colder climate
in the northern hemisphere you got to
start you got to be getting excited
right daylight savings
the snow's starting to thaw
right
the ladies
are starting to hit the gym
you're gonna hit the gym everybody's
gonna hit the gym
you know here comes me
may's right around the corner and
everybody you know the guy's got to get
out the guns
the ladies got to show off their thighs
everybody has to look desirable so
somehow they meet that certain someone
that's just going to hold them at night
and tell them that everything's going to
be okay but that's not going to happen
right
unless you're in shape by make
so put down those winner cookies
everybody may is coming april is a
[ __ ] wash
nobody gives a [ __ ] about april
except neo-nazis because hitler's
birthday is sometime in there right
and they all get together with their
awful haircuts and their stupid
mustaches
you know because they just want to be a
part of something and they had awful
parents who just didn't get him into
scouting
so what did they do instead they joined
the hitler youth you know why because
they're weak [ __ ] people
all right if you have to go out and join
a [ __ ] group
you know at any god damn age
you know unless it's something just fun
i guess being a neo-nazi it's got to
have its upsides
right the boots
you know
getting to borrow your other [ __ ]
nazi friends
clippers
when you share off the side of your
skull whatever the [ __ ] you do
i don't [ __ ] i don't want the [ __ ]
i'm talking about you know [ __ ] groups
my groups can be all right
you know i guess they can be okay i'm
trying to think of a good group what's a
good group
like just a group of people
that get together in a group and somehow
they're not [ __ ] annoying i mean
there's even people out there where i
agree with what they're doing but the
second the group gets the commercial on
tv
and they just start going you know every
day
over 8 000 poodles get their hair
straightened against their will i mean
they start showing the sad foot i start
[ __ ] hating the poodle people i don't
hate poodles i don't like them
you know but i feel like they should
wear their hair the way they want to
i'm definitely for that but i don't need
some [ __ ]
former sitcom star
who's put on some goddamn booze of baby
weight coming up the [ __ ] screen in
the middle of the goddamn game telling
me why i gotta
care about a [ __ ] pekingese or
whatever the [ __ ] kind of dog it is
one of those goddamn dogs you see
[ __ ]
walking around in a purse
right
these [ __ ]
women walking around never had a baby or
want a baby so now they got to have this
[ __ ] little primate in there
give me my little baby
baby right now
can you give me your baby
due to the back of the head no trial in
my world
if i was running [ __ ] you know
that probably seems harsh but did i say
i'd feed my naked uncle to a bunch of
dogs like old fat face over there
huh
how soft does that guy look kind that
fat [ __ ] over there and [ __ ] uh what
do you call it uh north korea is that
what we're calling nowadays the old nk
he looks soft
you could take that guy down
you know
call his number little pitch out run the
old packers sweep
your job's to force it to the inside
yeah i come in i fill the [ __ ] lane
you don't think i'm gonna drill him
right between his [ __ ] hairless man
tits
i'll knock some of his non-earned medals
right off his [ __ ] uniform what do
you think about that i'll do that 45 i'm
calling it right now
calling it right now
all right red gets the a gap
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] um
anyways yeah so i'm back in
town i feel like i should have started a
song right there like one of those
[ __ ] beatles songs
where all the women start screaming and
yelling you know impregnate me that's
what they're saying
or are they saying i'll suck it i don't
know what they're saying but all of them
are well into their [ __ ] 60s at this
point all those [ __ ] young women that
you hear screaming on that sullivan show
you figure let's just say the medium age
was like what 13 years old that was 50
[ __ ] years ago they're 63 years 63
years old at this point
you know
that's how quick
it [ __ ] goes
so that's my message to you this week
everybody
all right i don't i have no [ __ ]
message
i'm just happy to be home my [ __ ]
brains all over the goddamn place
you know
it's just all over the [ __ ] place
as it always is
i don't have any [ __ ] desire to do
stand-up
for a while
i gotta tell you i got my fill of it
on that tour 22 [ __ ] shows doing
about an hour and a half a night in 20
days i've had enough
i've had enough of the uh what's up with
the [ __ ] lamp over there okay
i'm gonna take at least
10 days off
i'm not doing [ __ ] dude you guys know i
came home i barely left the [ __ ]
house
my wife's looking at me like i'm a
psycho because i'm usually like i get
home for two seconds i throw my bags
down and then i walk out the door
and she'll just be like where are you
going and i'm just like
i'm like i'm all [ __ ] wound up
i just feel like i have to go out i just
i don't know where i go
drive around go [ __ ] play drums
i don't know what i do the [ __ ] do i do
drink
i have no [ __ ] idea i can tell you
right now though um
i'm all in with the cigar [ __ ] though
after my uh
my my second stop in calgary
um
we met like this we went to the cigar
bar out there for the second time me and
verzi and uh
met this character and a half that ran
this cigar bar [ __ ] great guy and he
just all he has is cubans
in his uh in his shop
and dude he broke down the whole [ __ ]
thing
how they're wrapped
how to cut the thing i mean just going
right it'd be like you know if you
played i don't know a sport and then
like a [ __ ] pro came in and just
broke your game down to the basics
that's what this guy did and um
we smoked these things uh
i'm gonna say it right
uh partagas
the number
twos and um
at this point that's the only reason why
i would get on a [ __ ] plane this week
would literally be to fly back to
calgary to get a box of those things
you know and then rent like a [ __ ]
you know dodge stratus
one way
to boise and then jump on a plane and
come back
that's the only [ __ ] reason i do that
[ __ ] i know i'm babbling
um
i'm all in
i'm all in i'm [ __ ] done that habit
got its hooks in me and uh i'm not
complaining but the great thing is i
live in the united states so i can't get
any [ __ ] cubans other than the
counterfeit ones
you know all they'll get give you one
that's hard as a [ __ ] rock and
doesn't have a good draw and you're just
sitting there like i might as well be
smoking a dutch master so
um
whatever what are you gonna do this
would be something i'm gonna do when i
leave the country i'm just gonna smoke
[ __ ] cubans and then when i come back
i'm gonna act like it never happened you
know like a sex offender right goes to
thailand does whatever the [ __ ] he does
and then comes back and then you know
that shit's not available here and then
you just go about your business i'll
just do that in in a
[ __ ] cigar kind of way
um
anyways what the [ __ ] did i want to talk
about here um
but oh and and and once again i know i
was thanking everybody for the last few
weeks uh thank you to everybody who came
out to the shows that was really
a life-changing tour and uh canada is
now in the loop
and um
you know when i write my next hour
i'm gonna do the usual tour of the
states
the usual tour of europe usual tour of
uh australia and now canada is i'm added
i'm adding that
so that's the deal i'm just gonna keep
expanding the [ __ ] circle
and uh
you know
the [ __ ] else am i gonna make perfect i
get on a [ __ ] plane i sit there i
read a dumb magazine i get off
there's somebody standing there going
are you the freckled [ __ ] that's gonna
dance like a monkey and i say i i am
your huckleberry
and they see how many bags do you have
and i say well i got one
and they go is that your bag right there
and i say you know what it is that is my
bag
and then when i i say you don't need to
pick it up it's got wheels on it's not
the [ __ ] 70s we got to be a goddamn
man
have some sort of [ __ ] forearm
strength i can just carry this like a
golf bag on one of those little wheelie
things
we walk to the car i go to the hotel i
get a [ __ ] burger
go to sleep i get up in the morning do
the [ __ ] radio and that night do the
show and then i leave
no boss
no [ __ ] inventory
no nothing
i just gotta dance like a monkey for a
[ __ ] hour that's all i gotta get my i
got to get my [ __ ]
monkey ass there and then i just do my
thing and then i leave
no [ __ ] no conference calls
no support system
no friends no anybody else it's just me
all right
i know it's not perfect um
hey you know what i actually do have to
[ __ ] uh
believe it or not i do have to take
another flight this week i can't [ __ ]
believe it uh because um
uh yours truly is getting ready to uh
pick a theater
to uh shoot his next special
may junish
i'm ready to go
this hour is ready to go ready to be
recorded ready to be put the [ __ ] bed
to move on to the next one
and um
i'm not excited about going to the
airport i'm not gonna [ __ ] lie to you
but i am excited to just [ __ ] land
and pick one
i'm going to try to pick a theater that
has a combination of uh the vibe where i
feel like i'm going to kill in the room
and uh of the least [ __ ] union guys you
know that's basically how i'm gonna do
it you know there's [ __ ] union guys
i'm so pro union it's ridiculous and
then you get around union guys you're
like oh this is why people don't like
unions
you know
i i one of the times i i i can't
remember which [ __ ] special was
i taped at this place right
and
they were required to have four guys
working the stage because usually bands
play there and i get it okay
so i gotta pay three guys who aren't
going to do [ __ ] [ __ ] but it's like
can you at least just have the decency
to [ __ ] off then go in the back room and
play cards rather than just sitting
there in the chair right out in the open
like look yeah yeah i ain't doing [ __ ]
and you're paying me
you know just have a little [ __ ] tact
i get it it's your house your rules i'm
in your world but you know
[ __ ] unbelievable um you've literally
become what you were fighting i feel
you know or maybe i'm just being a
douche
who knows you know maybe i am
i don't [ __ ] know but uh that's what
i'm doing this week i'm gonna pick out a
venue
and um
as always then the game plans to get the
uh
figure out roughly
what jokes i'm gonna try and do and uh
see what happens that night and
hopefully i outdo my last special
because you know you just compete
against yourself that's all you could do
um all right this is the monday morning
podcast i uh i do one of these every
single week and uh i'm actually
recording this sunday night which is why
um
it came out a little bit earlier i
usually record it monday mornings
wherever i'm at which is why it's called
the monday morning podcast despite the
fact that most people consider it well
it should be during my monday
you know
the typical internet [ __ ] the demanding
cuts who then have turn around and have
the nerve
to look at celebrities and be like oh
look at look at their diva-ish behavior
and they don't see the seed of it
in themselves
you know what i mean
they don't see
that you know if they actually had their
own show that maybe they would be the
[ __ ] they never see it these internet
[ __ ]
never
they never [ __ ] see it
they're the same [ __ ] people that
[ __ ] about how there's no original
movies coming out
while they go to pirate bay and steal
all the movies
and nobody can make any [ __ ] money so
basically they're either going to make
like a low budget movie at this point
are they going to make it transformers
because even if you steal it it's not
going to be as cool i guess if you went
down to the imax and you saw the blue
people trying to [ __ ] each other with
the umbilical cords whatever the [ __ ]
that movie was
what was that called argo they began
with an a
action
what the [ __ ] was that movie called god
damn it i used it as a reference for
like two years
apocalypto
whatever it was it was a [ __ ] chick
flick it was like if you took the smurfs
and you stretched them out
you know like that good times art that
jj allegedly was painting you remember
that
except you did that with the smurfs and
then they they [ __ ] each other and
wrote a dragon
i think somewhere in there there was
criticism about america's foreign policy
i believe it was james cameron wasn't he
the same guy who did the titanic
right
with that chick who punched herself in
the cleavage would sing that song in the
obs of an angel
riding on the front of a ship
um
all right here we go let's do the
advertising for this way uh legalzoom
everybody
okay legalzoom everyone if the
excitement of starting your business
getting your first customer and finally
quitting your damn job has it moved you
to action yet well here's another good
reason to get started it's national
start your business month everybody
all right
national get out of your cubicle and
start your own damn business month at
legalzoom and legalzoom wants to help
you start your own corporation or llc or
file your dba so you can get up and
running quickly and easily find out why
more than one million entrepreneurs use
legalzoom to start down the path of
successful business ownership this month
only take advantage of their national
start your business month special and
get a free three-month trial of the
all-new quickbooks making it so much
easier to run your business that's a 119
dollar value for absolutely free when
you enter bur b-u-r-r in the referral
box at checkout that's legalzoom.com
promo code burr legalzoom provides
self-help services and connect and can
connect you with the right attorney but
they are not a law firm legalzoom
promo code burr b-u-r-r
[ __ ] hilarious i had one read and i
butchered the [ __ ] out of it
you know that's like the afternoon
hockey game right the team never [ __ ]
shows up
uh speaking of hockey how about those
bruins huh good lord
i knew that they were on a little run
there
when i was up in canada i saw a little
bit of it but i was so damn busy i
didn't get to watch too many of the
games although i watched him kick the
[ __ ] habs ass fought and nothing
in their own building
um
yeah i believe they've won uh like 13 in
a row i watched the last two
they look uh they look i mean they
played phoenix gives a [ __ ] right
phoenix
and for the life of me i can't remember
who they played before that
because after it's over i don't [ __ ]
remember it anymore
um
but either way you know what i watch
today and i actually if the bro if you
know if the bruins don't get to the
finals or whatever the the team that i'm
gonna root for this year to win the
stanley cup is uh
is the st louis blues
you know
they've never won a cup
okay and they've had a lot of bad years
and they have great fans
and they made a lot of great moves and
you know they got ryan miller
which was a strong move and uh although
i gotta tell you if the way they played
today against the penguins
if they're gonna start doing that [ __ ]
it's gonna be hard to [ __ ] root for
them you know
why don't they just open up the damn
game again and everybody stopped [ __ ]
with this insane goddamn defense and
blocking the shots already
you know i actually looked up some stats
this week believe it or not i'm not just
going to just make up [ __ ] i actually
looked it up do you realize sydney
crosby for all the [ __ ] goddamn glory
they give that guy he's only scored 50
goals in a season once
patrick kane has never done it ovechkin
i think has done it like twice
and it's a [ __ ] disgrace
i'm not saying it's on them just the way
the games played back in the day there'd
be like four or five guys who get 50
goals a year for like four seasons in a
row that was their height [ __ ]
gretzky was getting like 90 70 60. it
was [ __ ] insane
the guy scored like 300 goals in about
five years i know he's one of the
greatest
but i mean there was all those other guy
mike bossie was good for 50 a year for
about three four years
you just never see it anymore
i don't [ __ ] get it
[ __ ] [ __ ] man bringing one of
the forwards back with the defense it
just gets boring after a while let him
let him score some goddamn goals all
right
they're trying right they're trying to
make the pads a little smaller i don't
know what the [ __ ] i'm talking about
um
you know what's funny i really have
nothing to talk about this week i just
realized that [ __ ] because i'm not doing
anything
i'm not doing anything you know they
finally started the construction the
rebuild
downstairs
after all the [ __ ] [ __ ]
the back and forth the back and forth
the back and the four it's literally a
year later and now they're finally uh
you know they finished the upstairs room
and then downstairs there was a bunch of
crap
you know back and forth with that [ __ ]
so i finally got my insurance money back
from my uh
mortgage company i got all of it back
and uh for those of you in the banking
system you know what that means
um
so they're actually they're finally uh
gonna rebuild down there which is nice
i'm excited
but what sucks
is everything from downstairs had to
[ __ ] come upstairs and it's an
absolute [ __ ] show and it's depressing
it's depressing you know it's really
depressing not that that they're doing
this stuff it's i just realized how much
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and the key word is [ __ ] that i've saved
over the years that i wish i never saved
because now i can't throw it out i had
this thing where i would [ __ ] any
stand-up show i did if there was a
comedy t-shirt i just folded it and i
stuck it in a [ __ ]
plastic container
and you know i've been doing it for 22
years now i have everything back
from the first one i did
right on through
i mean i got everything i got a jim
norton down and dirty with jim norton
hoodie zip up i mean i wouldn't throw
that one out but like
some of the other ones i have a bunch of
comedy central [ __ ]
and i can't throw it out because i'm
sentimental and but i'm never going to
wear any of it it's just going to sit in
a [ __ ] container until i die
so
i got rid of all my cassette tapes
which was a big [ __ ] move for me i'm
a bit of a pack rack
pat rat like sentimental kind of thing
my next move is i'm getting rid of all
my [ __ ] cds i'm just gonna do it
it's weird i get sad when i go to do it
and then after i do it i feel like this
weight off of my chest like here's a
[ __ ] up thing for you when i did a uh
long time ago i did a gig on tv and
you know it was one of those deals when
they had like 100 comics did it and one
of the things they did was they gave you
uh
they gave you uh
a nice piece of luggage which i always
thought was funny like you know hey he
did the show great job thanks for
burning the material now get back on the
road you [ __ ] hack
because we own that material now you
know
so um that was back in 2005 and the bag
they gave me it finally gave out
where it was gradually ripping
yeah [ __ ] up yarding here it was
gradually ripping and then finally my
last flight from newark when it was
coming down the belt i could literally
see my clothes in it so i was like all
right it's time to get rid of this
[ __ ] thing um of course i was gonna
try to get a repair and get it sewed up
and my wife was like bill why don't you
just [ __ ] buy a new one all right so
i said fine
so i actually took the bag over to
goodwill today with some other [ __ ]
that i threw in there
and i had to set it down quickly and
walk away so i wouldn't be thinking of
like but i got that from that tv gig
i did a half hour it was important to me
and that bag was the gift from it like
i'm a [ __ ] idiot like that
i literally walked up and i set it down
and the guy at goodwill goes thank you
sir you want a receipt and i was like no
it's all good and i [ __ ] had to run
back to the car
i need to get over that
i got to kick some [ __ ] out of the nest
i was in my garage i got a bunch of [ __ ]
in there too that used to be in this the
place where that flooded
and i'm just looking at all of it all of
the games i went to all of the programs
and the hats and all that [ __ ] crap
that i got
and i was just like from here on out
i go to a sporting event i just keep the
ticket stub i'm not getting anything
else no more [ __ ] programs no more
hats
no more hankies towels any of that
[ __ ] [ __ ] because
i just save it and i never look at it
i'm not gonna look i have
football program from a giants playoff
game at the meadowlands in 2002.
i played the vikings or some [ __ ] i know
the la play i never read it i didn't
read it the day i got it jim fossils on
the cover or something the face of the
[ __ ] you say his name he's on the cover
i've never read the thing i'm never
gonna read the thing
if i actually took it and put it on
[ __ ] ebay i could maybe get 40 cents
for it what am i doing with it and for
the rest of my life every time i move or
get water damage that's yet another
thing i have to [ __ ] pick up
so if you're young
all right
and you just moved out of your parents
house and you got a little closet full
of [ __ ]
try to keep it at that
sorry for the long pause i'm yawning
here
try to keep it at that
all right because uh it's just it's just
a bunch of [ __ ]
i got old cell phones old flip phones oh
old [ __ ]
video recording things that i used
i got all these vhs s tapes from when i
first did stand up now i gotta try to
convert those to dvd and then what dvds
running out i don't [ __ ] know what to
do with all of it
um
so
i'm gonna get rid of a bunch of [ __ ] is
what i'm telling you and then i'm gonna
i already i already fixed my t-shirt
game
where because i'm a sentimental fool
i i don't buy t-shirts that say anything
on them anymore i just buy plain gray
black
red white that's it and when they wear
out they're all pilly looking i just
[ __ ] toss them out and that's it
i don't remember where i wore them to
what and then i'm good
and uh
that's it why am i going through all of
this [ __ ] [ __ ]
i also think too you know the back of my
head
just as a married man now
you know the marriage is going great and
everything but i'm just saying you know
if you ever get [ __ ] divorced
right get all your [ __ ] and get the [ __ ]
out if you just walk in with like one
army bag and just throw like five things
in there and then you're out
just let it keep the rest of it who
gives a [ __ ]
right
do you want all those knickknacks well
this voice just cracked knickknacks
those knickknacks is that what you want
you want the drapes
the throw pillows and all those [ __ ]
egg beaters and [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] you
well i can't go to ikea
and go buy a bastardized version of the
[ __ ] ridiculously nice [ __ ] that we
had to buy for some stupid reason to
dish out eggs i don't give a [ __ ]
i don't give a [ __ ] although i will tell
you i don't think i could ever go back
to apartment living
you know once you get out from [ __ ]
living under and over people and
smelling their food
and and hearing their arguments and
listening to their [ __ ] music
but why am i yawning so much
am i making you guys time supposed to be
waking you guys up for the work week
all right you want to hear some petty
[ __ ] at a [ __ ] death level
do you guys see that turkey shot down
one of syria's jets
syria is basically in the middle of a
civil war right now right so they're
having a battle right along the turkish
border
so they're in the middle of fighting a
fight this syrian jet pilot is [ __ ]
fighting rebels i'm not taking sides
here i don't know what the [ __ ] going
on i know our country's with the [ __ ]
rebels
and uh russia's with the [ __ ] uh
powers that be but i know both sides
don't give a [ __ ] about the syrian
people they don't give a [ __ ] they don't
give a [ __ ] about me why the [ __ ] would
they give a [ __ ] about syria they give a
[ __ ] about the money
that's what they give a [ __ ] about this
just the strategic [ __ ] of the
[ __ ]
wherever the land is or whatever that's
what to give a [ __ ] about so anyways
this pilot is fighting a good fight okay
and he's looking for rebels and then out
of nowhere these two turkish jets and
one comes in
and [ __ ] shoots a missile and
whatever the [ __ ] shot at it and uh
shoots the damn plane down
that's like in hockey third man in
that's a 10-minute misconduct that's a
gay misconduct and that's probably a
10-game suspension or is that coming
over the boards first
i can't remember which but whatever
turkey went third man in on syria and i
was like wow what the [ __ ] did they do
that foreign series like how the [ __ ]
could you do that to us
and then you know what turkey said
hang on i gotta there was actually some
good [ __ ] talk here my turkey i got i
got to give it up to turkey this week
[ __ ] talk of the week
this is what they said
said a syrian plane violated our
airspace
our f-16s took off and hit the plane why
because if you violate my airspace
airspace
our slap after this will be hard
now i know something was lost in
translation there
um
i like that though
i like the way the dude was going if you
violate my airspace
you know
like when they have like the the [ __ ]
grizzled vet cop
you know what is that what are those
drugs doing on my street
this is my street you know that [ __ ]
because if you violate my airspace our
slap after this will be hard
now you know we didn't say it like that
something got lost in translation what
will you really say because if you
violate my airspace i'm gonna slap you
right in your [ __ ]
syrian face i don't know what the [ __ ]
he said man that's too harsh so anyways
that's what they said so i read a little
bit more and it turns out you know what
syria did this to turkey like two
[ __ ] years ago
turkey said we were just flying some
[ __ ] you know some
uh learn how to fly at jet missions with
our guys near the turkey and syrian
border and syria's like ow [ __ ] you no
you weren't you were spying on us
and they gave me all right there fred
they gave him the old right right there
fred
they shot down their [ __ ]
jet so this is what they're doing over
there
that's like
literally
two children in the back seat talking
about who touched who first and they're
shooting down people in jets it's just
[ __ ] unreal
you know back in the day i used to think
people who ran countries and were in
higher power there was just something
at the core of them they were they would
just uh
i don't know there was something wrong
with them that they were these evil
people and all that type of [ __ ] and if
they just let regular people go around
doing their [ __ ] thing everything
would be fine if they weren't so [ __ ]
greedy and start rumors about everybody
and i don't believe it anymore
i don't
i just think it's uh
it's just human nature
the higher up you go the more power you
get the more of a [ __ ] you become
and eventually you get to the point
where you have so much power
that you want to [ __ ] make the order
to shoot something down
as you're standing there in your [ __ ]
rope right open robe of course
balls hanging out you got that red phone
you're just feeling the power coursing
through your [ __ ] vagues
you know
you're smoking a cohiba
oh is that what they did well we're
going to slap them back you get to talk
[ __ ]
right you get to turn the world into
your own [ __ ] video game that's what
they're doing there you know like those
[ __ ] weirdos that play video games
online and they wear like those
mcdonald's headsets and they talk [ __ ]
and they call each other [ __ ]
you know as they play these war games
these guys are doing that for real
i don't know what my [ __ ] point is
and all that i just think that uh
i i know it's not an original theory i
really believe that we are
designed to destroy ourselves eventually
and it's gonna happen
all right and what you have to do as a
selfish person like me is just pray that
it doesn't happen during your lifetime
or at least during the quality years
you know
when you get to those older years when
you really start slowing down your
shuffling years
before it becomes the sit-down years
and then the lay down years and then
like they are right already years and
then the [ __ ]
you know
whatever than the end
[Laughter]
i just hope it doesn't happen you know i
know the polar ice caps are going to
melt completely i know we're not going
to do anything about it i know new york
city miami and all them are going to be
underwater i know it is i just hope
it's not during my lifetime
i mean i recycle i bring back the cans
and the bottles
i do what i can
i forget my little [ __ ] recyclable
bags i go with the paper
the papers the papers right what the
[ __ ] else am i gonna do
you
know i don't [ __ ] know what do you
guys think
do you guys think we're doomed
some people believe that we're gonna
we're gonna do something [ __ ]
horrific
right
and then when we come out of it
we're somehow all collectively
gonna learn a lesson from it and then
we're gonna live in this utopia
and then jesus comes back i can't
remember there's so many [ __ ]
theories out there but i just love that
whole theory that after we [ __ ] have
some sort of nuclear holocaust
and we somehow
survive it and we're sitting there
eating glowing pears that were somehow
that the uh
basically the you know what we are we're
defective that somehow the defect is
just gonna repair itself
that we're not gonna be petty we're not
gonna be jealous we're not gonna be
lustful
you know all the seven deadly sins
whatever the [ __ ] they are
you know
like that cures that i don't think it
does
i don't think it does and that's my
gloom and doom for this week everybody i
think we're i think we're [ __ ]
uh we don't have a goddamn prayer but
going back i am uh rooting for the st
louis blues in the west i'm rooting for
him i like chicago i like st louis i
like the [ __ ] west
for some reason i'm liking the ducks i
don't know why
i know why teemu solani i just like that
guy i like the fact that he weighs less
than he did when he [ __ ] was a rookie
something to aspire to
um
who else do i like out there
i never got into san jose although i
respect their fans i went to a home game
they're [ __ ] rabid
um
i like the kings
um i i kind of liked vancouver until we
played him in the finals
that little jerk off there biting what's
his face on his finger you know it was
kind of weird
um
yeah i just like the west the west was
cool when i was growing up they were
good edmonton was good calgary was good
uh
i was canoe the king sucked until
gretzky got there
they had their moments though right i
don't know what the [ __ ] i'm talking
about but the blues the blues were
always you know expansion six
just never caught a break
never caught a [ __ ] break so they do
so that's that's the team that i'm gonna
[ __ ] root for all right and with that
let's get to some questions mercifully
let's get to [ __ ]
some goddamn questions this week
uh let's see if i can try and make an
hour i've already looked at it like 10
times all right 37 minutes can i do 23
minutes of [ __ ]
through all of these uh these questions
here all right march
madness dear billy brackets
i'm not a huge college sports fan i love
sports so i can enjoy a good game but
i'm not interested in following a season
march madness is fun for anyone because
of the brackets if there was another
game on a national level with bracket
talk and exposure you could have a chat
you could have chess be interesting to
watch on tv agree or disagree 100
percent agree
100 percent agree if that's like a great
idea if they actually had whatever i
don't even know when the the the
international chess championship is but
if they set up brackets
and they had like you know four regions
you know you broke up
the the northern hemisphere and the
southern hemispheres
and the sides of the world
and he had number one seeds and all that
type of [ __ ] abso-fucking-lutely if you
had brackets
you know i 100 agree with that and um
i haven't really watched [ __ ] i watched
a little bit of a tar heel game today
and then i fell asleep because uh
i'm [ __ ] old man
um
but i i haven't been following any of it
any of it you know
down to the sweet 16 the grade eight the
final four i mean i know it's amazing
i i just don't uh i don't have time i
have too much [ __ ] invested in the uh
watching hockey and it's coming down to
it and i uh
i like watching it
you know so we know it's a number one
big criticism
especially of people who don't watch
hockey in another way i'm going to
defend the [ __ ] sport is people say
that the regular season doesn't mean
[ __ ] it's one of the biggest criticisms
of kids the regular season doesn't mean
[ __ ] everybody makes the [ __ ]
playoffs yeah kind of like in basketball
how about baseball do you really need to
play 162
[ __ ] games to figure out who wins the
division
you know
and then after all that [ __ ]
someone's still gonna get a wild card
i mean come on
the only regular season of the four
major sports that means anything is
football that's why it's so [ __ ]
exciting and even they are gonna [ __ ]
that up
they should have just left it on sunday
the monday night game fine but sunday
you play every [ __ ] sunday you don't
get a day off you play every [ __ ]
sunday
you don't get a week off i mean they
just did that to prolong the [ __ ]
season so they could advertise more
now they're gonna start working in
thursday night they're gonna try to
somehow if they can figure it out
they're gonna [ __ ] try and do it at
least four to five times a goddamn week
and and it's gonna ruin the sport
it's going to ruin it
all right
and it's because millionaires can't be
happy being millionaires they have to
try to be billionaires and then they got
to try to be multi-billionaires and then
they got to try to go global and that
you just can't just [ __ ] just be like
hey you know what i have enough
you know look at my car look at my house
look at that [ __ ] uh look at my wife
look at her she's bending over look at
her
it's my wife she had three kids looking
good she looks
you know that's not enough you just
gotta keep [ __ ] going
um
but yeah but that's one of the major
things where they say that the uh the
regular season doesn't mean [ __ ] um
i disagree
i know what you mean we're [ __ ] a ton
of teams make it
but uh you know half the t after league
doesn't [ __ ] make it i don't want to
tell you that's the same way in
basketball how many don't say that about
basketball
you know basketball is the exact same
[ __ ] thing and
the end of the game when it's most the
most exciting part of the game two
minutes to go
you're up by three they stopped the
clock like 58 [ __ ] times
foul foul foul timeout foul tv timeout
technical foul
kicked the ball went off his foot it
just [ __ ]
the final two minutes of an nba game i
swear to god it takes like [ __ ] 18
minutes to play and it destroys
it's even funny all the drama it's even
funnier when you go to a [ __ ] nba
game
it'll be a game with playoff
implications and any time there's a
stoppage of play
all hell breaks loose and these [ __ ]
[ __ ] go out and start doing uh uh
jumping jacks and shooting t-shirts and
then they start playing like music way
too [ __ ] loud and it completely
takes you out of uh the drama of the
game
so i i don't know
whatever whatever i don't even know why
i'm [ __ ] bringing this [ __ ] up
you know why because people who don't
watch hockey don't even understand it
[ __ ] all over it why do they have two
half times
have you ever played first of all that
mathematically it doesn't [ __ ] make
sense it's not two half times okay
there's two thirty third and a third
times that's what you want to say 33rd
or third time and then it's a [ __ ] 66
and two-thirds time
that's what you want to say
um if you ever played it you're [ __ ]
after one shift your heart is [ __ ]
about ready to come out of your chest
that's why
um all right
boring here we go i'm probably talking
about the podcast here uh dear billiam
i'm 25 years old and graduated college a
few years ago and have been living in
chicago since
i hate it
matty hates chicago man he goes it's not
that chicago isn't a great city but what
what it is
but but what is it that happens to
people when they get in their 20s and
30s they enjoy the dumbest [ __ ] i don't
want to go to the same bar and taxi
around and get food no one seems to be
interested in anything fun anymore the
only exercise my friends get is at the
gym and they don't do anything fun like
basketball and none of them are in good
shape because they're on their asses all
day everyone is a boring sellout
there is no spice in their life in their
lives am i an [ __ ] or are they
um
neither
it's all about what makes you happy the
people you're hanging out with aren't
doing the things that you want to do so
you're not happy hanging out with them
but they sound happy as hell
to go to the gym and then sit on their
ass and have a beer and eat some [ __ ]
nachos
and if that's what makes them happy
they're entitled to it what you need to
do
sir or ma'am is you need to go find
yourself some new friends you got to go
find some active people
i mean there's plenty of you telling me
there's nobody in there out in chicago
there's no there's not 19 000 [ __ ] uh
pickup leagues of hoop
hockey
flag football wally ball
water polo rugby there's all kinds of
[ __ ] you could be doing
and uh
if i was 25 years old i would get into a
co-ed league
co-ed [ __ ] league you find yourself
uh
pretty girl that likes sports you like
sports she's active you're active
you know you got a dick she got a vagina
yeah there you go
what more do you need
right
[ __ ] if i can go back and be 25 years
old again i take up field hockey
those chicks always had [ __ ]
beautiful legs right the tan [ __ ]
thighs
you know short haircuts you got to be
like all right you're still into me are
you uh cutting into uh the same chick
i'm staring at
i'll be a wingman [ __ ] it can i watch um
[Laughter]
yeah dude you're not an [ __ ]
what it is is you've decided
to continue living an active life at 25
years old as opposed to just settling in
you know
certain people out there they get uh
they get old
they just get [ __ ] i mean there's a
party that you you know getting old you
can kind of accept it
um
like i view uh i love living like an old
man
if it means being smart
like uh
like take it like you know
like if i want to get shit-faced
all right
which i do
i don't know if you guys listen to this
podcast every week but i like to go out
and get i like to get [ __ ] hammered
um
i just do it at my house
your house is the greatest [ __ ] bar
you could ever be at if you're in a if
you're in a [ __ ] house i don't have
upstairs downstairs neighbors nothing
okay i got a wife and a dog
and i'm stronger than both of them all
right well my dog can [ __ ] me up but it
doesn't realize it
it loves me so much that it would never
turn its pit bull powers on me but as
far as my wife i mean i'll take it down
to the mat right you can tell i said
that
um so if i want to get [ __ ] up in my
own house i'm going to do it i can
[ __ ] put on the music i want to put
on
i can pop in a dvd watch a little bit of
good fellas i don't have to deal
i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm talking
about right now
i mean to me like
the way to get shit-faced now is for me
to be hanging with one other friend
on my front porch smoking a cigar and
drinking some scotch and listening to
some [ __ ] music
and just shooting the [ __ ]
it's quiet
you know when you're younger i guess you
want the [ __ ] louder and that type of
thing but whatever like to me
i don't feel like an old man doing that
i just feel like i'm smarter like back
in the day i used to go to a club
damaging my hearing and the [ __ ]
music was loud and all that type of [ __ ]
but that worked for me back then because
i didn't know how to talk to the ladies
by all means drown out the horrible [ __ ]
that's coming out of my mouth ah with my
z cavalry cheese what was i doing
uh
but uh yeah dude you know what 25 is uh
that's a great age
and uh it's a critical age
where you're starting to surround
yourself
with the people that you're really going
to be hanging out with for the rest of
your life you kind of left most of your
high school friends behind
uh not in a bad way you just your paths
don't cross anymore so you're going to
get some new friends
and uh yeah get friends who want to
[ __ ] live life
who want to go do some [ __ ]
other than you know hey let's go to
[ __ ]
wherever the [ __ ] they where do people
go
where do they go cabo st lucas where the
where those hacky places everybody let's
go to aruba the places everybody goes
and then they go there they jump off a
bar stool in chicago and then they jump
on a bar stool in a in a [ __ ] bar
pool
and sit there right isn't it great it's
not as cold and i can piss myself
without going to the [ __ ] bathroom
we live in a what it's like no we're
kind of doing the same thing in better
weather better scenery and that type of
thing
um
yeah if you go to aruba you should get
outside the [ __ ] place and walk
around hopefully not get murdered like
that chick you know
go find a waterfall and jerk off and you
know enjoy the planet
all right prince harry
prince harry uh not sure if you heard
this recently but prince harry came out
i think we say came out of the closet i
was like jesus christ i gotta start
watching the news
he came out and said something to his
brother the future king that he's not
going to be king so he doesn't need to
be on his best behavior
dude that's [ __ ] great
you know other than his [ __ ] dressing
up like a [ __ ] ss officer i don't
have a problem with that kid uh my
question to you is it's kind of a major
other than that time he dressed like
hitler you know he's a bad guy
my question to you is what happened if
he began to speak out against atrocities
in the world like his mother or call out
bankers and evil bastards running the
world's resources would they bump him
off uh yeah absolutely
absolutely oh and did i call that
[ __ ] bitcoin thing
people telling me to get on that you
gotta invest in this bitcoin thing
they're gonna take that thing down
they're gonna ignore it and laugh at it
first just like gandhi you know
first they ignore you then they laugh at
you
then they fight you then you win right
isn't that well go something like that i
don't know what i don't know [ __ ]
ghosts but whatever
that bitcoin [ __ ] you know i'm sure the
banks are like well i don't think that's
going to be a viable car you think it'll
be uh for sale future they did all that
[ __ ] right then they started you know
going oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] they get a little bit of
traction people are talking about this
stuff and then what happens
what happens
somebody commits suicide
conveniently conveniently and everybody
around is going hey it doesn't seem like
that person commits suicide well you
know that's what happens when you try to
start a new currency
you know what do you think is going to
happen do you think these [ __ ] fudder
duddies are going to [ __ ]
fuddy-duddies or whatever you say is
going to sit around and tolerate that
they can't
their whole life
lives are are invested in the lie of
their currency
you can't come along with a new lie
then they got to start all over again
it's like a red sox fan becoming a
yankee fan it's not going to happen it's
not even a yankee fan it's going to be a
whole new [ __ ] league like the xfl
ain't happening go [ __ ] yourself
the nfl is where we got our money
[ __ ] your league
um
so anyways yeah do i think if he started
speaking out against the atrocities um
not if he just started speaking out
against
atrocities i i don't think uh
what they do is they join it
like kennedy with the civil rights we
can't control a million african
americans coming into washington what do
we do we join it and then we take
control of it and then you give your
permits and the next thing you know they
control the [ __ ] thing right
that's what they would do they would
just join you know prince prince uh
whatever the [ __ ] his name is
tells his brother's name
george
that's a good king name
the [ __ ] is his name christopher harry
and uh all right if i'm lady die if i if
i was dumb enough to name my my second
kid harry
i guess the other one had to be a little
bit better larry
nah there's no way you're gonna have
your kids nicknames rhyme
what the [ __ ] would his name be it's
gotta be some english
something [ __ ]
proper
not louis that's french
is it henry is henry is harry a nickname
for henry i don't [ __ ] know
george i'm gonna go george
not jesus i feel like the number five in
the line in the family feud you know
when the first person won whatever
category it is and he said the obvious
one and then somebody's the second
person said what i was thinking of and
then three and four somehow didn't get
strikes and now it's down to me and
there's like no [ __ ] answer left i'm
going with george
and everybody just looks at me and goes
hey good answer good answer right
survey says big [ __ ] x and then the
other team [ __ ] steals it and then
nobody talks to me at christmas um
yeah the only way that he would actually
get whacked
is it philip
hey nia
nia
nah jeez where the [ __ ] is she
i tell you you know they're never around
when you need them
what the [ __ ] am i talking about got the
internet right here is it charlie
charles
is he named after his dad
what the [ __ ] is his name
prince i'm just gonna look in prince
prince
harry
no possess no not possessive
harry's brother
i don't know what his [ __ ] name is
prince harry's brother
william it's my [ __ ] name what an
[ __ ]
oh billy
prince william duke of cambridge go [ __ ]
yourself your name's billy
hey belly
how are you gonna go ride a horse today
with your little [ __ ] stick
leaning over
you know be careful
it's a dangerous goddamn game
prince william
uh yeah they'd whack him the only way
they would whack him is if he was
effective
if when they went to join him
join his yeah we're sick of that [ __ ]
too that we're but we've created or it
was already created and now we have
positions they pass the baton to us and
we're continuing
to oppress people but that's how we make
money so we can have a bmw 7 series
right with the bulletproof [ __ ] glass
um they would join with him and if he
said no you're part of the [ __ ]
problem and then try to literally attack
the sectors that those people are in he
would definitely get whacked
uh he would die mysteriously he'd
probably commit suicide air quote
um
he would have some sort of i don't know
they you know they you know what they do
they spray the mist at you and you have
some sort of [ __ ]
they talk about you know he had a hole
in his heart that they had never
diagnosed before and they had an
arrhythmia
he had a uh cardiac episode he uh
and then
the conspiracy theory would come out and
then all the other [ __ ] [ __ ] mouth
breathing conspiracy theories would
muddy up the real conspiracy theory and
the whole [ __ ] thing would go away
that that's my guess
there you go that's my guess
jesus christ i almost did it 55 [ __ ]
minutes
55 minutes how you guys doing huh you
listening to this early what is it 10 30
in the morning getting ready for your
break there's a roach coach pulling up
you're gonna go with some drake's cakes
and a [ __ ] sausage king is that what
you're gonna do
all right live forever forever forever
forever
uh live forever billy infinity
i hate when people i hear people say who
would want to live that long
uh i guess he's referring or she's
referring to when someone is like just
they just turn 102 who would want to
live the lord
this guy says give me a pulse as long as
possible to people who say they wouldn't
want to live forever what do you say to
that
uh well i mean it comes down to quality
of life
i mean the human body is designed to
live for 150 years and then after all
the abuse that we do to it you usually
drop it about [ __ ] i guess 75.
um
i mean
i wouldn't want to live forever if like
i was just sitting there like
looking like yoda but without his
[ __ ] ability to flip around the room
with the lightsaber
um would i want to live forever
um
yeah if there's nothing after this [ __ ]
yeah
but i mean you know but then what you do
is you you would
you would watch us slowly kill ourselves
and then we would become extinct and
then you'd be the only one left
and then there'd be the next people
right
like i told you guys my theory right
that i i feel like water is the toxic
waste from the last people that [ __ ]
up this planet
and that is absolutely poisonous and
toxic to them but we
we came out of it
you know and we're walking around
thinking we're good-looking but we're
all a bunch of [ __ ] mutants compared
to the last people we don't know any
better because we can't look at them
right
so when we're done [ __ ] up this
planet the next people will come out of
the out of the the soup that we leave
which will have plastics and [ __ ] uh
you know old computers and all that [ __ ]
god knows what the [ __ ] they're gonna
look like you know
like i don't even know
but you know if you live forever you'd
be around with for them
no i wouldn't want to live forever
i wouldn't want to live forever because
i think eventually this planet's going
to look like mars and then you would
just be sitting there
well what would you do
sitting there kicking [ __ ] moon rocks
around forever
that's [ __ ] scary
if you just couldn't die
i don't know what i'd do
you know what i do is i i would try to
well
there's no there's no technology to do
it i would get a [ __ ] spaceship and
fly to the next earth
and i'd land there and hope that they
kind of look like me
it wasn't the dinosaur period or
whatever and you know there's like of
them was saying there's like uh
you know there's a bunch of earths out
there tens of thousands of them
throughout the [ __ ]
space the solar system i know what the
[ __ ] the word is
oh jesus i'm tired
you know guys sometimes these [ __ ]
questions they did
like do you guys realize like the level
of thought that how dumb i am you gotta
[ __ ] sit there march madness brackets
that's right in the [ __ ] wheelhouse
i guess two are easy my was with my
wheelhouse you know
prince harry
you don't even give me his brother's
name and then i gotta find out it's my
own [ __ ] name and you even said bill
in it so the answer was there it was a
clue
and then what i would i want to live
forever
i have to tell you i do want to see the
70s again
i was born in 1968 i'd like to live to
about 2072.
you know
provided new york and miami and
underwater that changes the whole deal
um
once that [ __ ] starts happening then
then i don't give a [ __ ]
you know
i'm bandwagon humanity i'm here for the
good times once it starts going the
other [ __ ] direction you know i'm i'm
tapping out
uh you this this i don't have any red
dawn in me
you know
i mean i would go up in a tower and just
start [ __ ] shooting at the powers
that be
i would do that i was kidding me i'd be
a [ __ ] i couldn't do that because i'd
be like oh that guy coming at me this
isn't his choice he's just taking orders
so i just shoot over their heads i'd
commit suicide that way you know they do
the people death by cop
i do it that way i think
i don't [ __ ] know all i know is i'm
back home
and i had a great tour up in canada
underrated remember that i used to do
that overrated underrated for the
[ __ ] week uh
underrated
canada man
canada canada canada you gotta [ __ ]
get up there dude it's [ __ ]
it's unreal
and the maritime uh specifically i would
definitely head up there uh if you're a
cigar smoker
you're out of your mind you got to get
up there uh
you know i was watching this thing on
the bruins and they got this great
segment that they do where they
interview the bruins and it's just like
they talk to him for three minutes where
no hockey questions it's really great
and every you see every player they're
so sick at answering questions about
playing hockey that
all of them it seems when they're
interviewing them they're already having
a good time just to be hearing new
questions and uh
brad marchand who then said you can call
him marshawn he doesn't give a [ __ ] so
i'm going back to marshawn is actually
an avid hunter
and i believe he's from halifax or
somewhere around there and um
he shot big [ __ ] like bear and he's
gonna go after elk and uh next
and i honestly i that's i couldn't do
that
i don't think i could do that i could
shoot a chicken
right
[Laughter]
i could shoot a cow but if i didn't kill
it on the first shot i would hear that
awful mooing for the rest of my [ __ ]
life why wouldn't you a coward shoot a
steer
that
is the guns jammed
ugh oh my god to be [ __ ] horrible
but i gotta be honest with you if every
everybody listens to this podcast if you
were hungry enough you would you would
[ __ ] you'd eat a puppy
you would
it's a sad reality
just the your your love of cute things
versus i'm gonna [ __ ] die if i don't
eat you it just goes right out the
goddamn window
you know what's the biggest animal you
think you could kill
biggest animal i could kill would be joe
derosa
he's a [ __ ] animal
um
actually what do we got here am i over
an hour did i make it all right now
we're in three minutes okay that's a
podcast for this week everybody this was
sort of my hungover
i had a great time up in canada podcast
uh
oh by the way
that paul versi jason lawhead joe
bartnick tour that the monday morning
podcast is sponsoring it's the all-in
tour
um and the first date is at lago and i'm
actually going to be hosting that one
and uh and kicking off the tour
all these guys in the past have opened
for me and now they're uh spreading
their wings doing their own [ __ ] tour
i'm so proud of them
um
and i'm going to be hosting the first
one down at largo it's already sold out
and uh we're going to be kicking that
one off
and then these guys i'm telling you
i don't bring cupcakes out on the road
these guys are all killers so if you
want to see three guys guys guys
all right
no [ __ ] none of that awkward you know
they don't say apparently before every
[ __ ] punchline
all right not saying that's bad but i'm
just saying it's not that [ __ ] style
all right
uh if you want to listen to three guys
[ __ ] hilarious who you probably would
sit next to in a bar these are the guys
the all-in tour we're gonna be getting
the dates up soon um they're gonna have
a [ __ ] cool ass poster i've already
heard the concept i [ __ ] love it and
uh i'm proud of these guys it's gonna be
a great tour so uh
definitely be looking for that
and uh
oh [ __ ] freckleface here is done i am
done with stand-up comedy until the end
of april i'm not doing [ __ ]
i am uh relaxing
and uh i think this is how i'm gonna i'm
gonna do my
my stand-up from here on out i'm just
gonna [ __ ] go out and go psycho for
[ __ ] 20 days and then take like a
month and a half off and then do another
psycho [ __ ] tour and that's what i'm
gonna do all or nothing
just the same way i drink
just [ __ ]
pounding
and then just i take a [ __ ] year off
for 70 days off and then i pound for
another 70 days that's it all or nothing
that's how i'm gonna do it all right um
that's the podcast for this week as
always thank you for everybody for
listening i hope you have a wonderful
week don't take any [ __ ]
all right
go [ __ ] yourselves
and uh any predictions
any predictions me and virzie are still
talking about that [ __ ] horrific
flight that they can't find
and he thinks it's on the ground i think
it's unfortunately uh
you know i think it's unfor i i actually
that that review that i that prediction
that that pilot made though he thought
there was some sort of fire on board or
something man it seems like it's that
it's [ __ ] that there's anything just
hanging
in the air you just want the answer to
it's got to be that man
it's [ __ ] poor families why do i
bring it was awful last week when we
brought it up why would i end the
podcast bringing that up stupid stupid
[ __ ] move but you know what you don't
listen to this thing because i'm smart
that's it
all right
i got nothing to predict
i got something to predict i'm not gonna
do [ __ ] between here and next week i
better get a [ __ ] guest i actually
got to call dom herrera i'm going to try
to do one with him dominio
[Music]
you're italian
you're not german you're not irish or a
jew i'm gonna leave that on this [ __ ]
answer machine all right go [ __ ]
yourselves i'll see you
you